let me ask you about the a Twitter poll
you posted a ten thousand dollar death
poll you tweeted if someone offered you
ten thousand dollars but if you take it
a random person on Earth dies would you
take the ten thousand dollars and uh
forty five percent of people said yes
that's at least at the time I checked
850 000 people committing murder
for just 8.5 billion dollars in total so
uh what do you learn about human nature
from that that's a a good question
um honestly is this is like late at
night when I threw that up too I was
just like huh this will be a funny thing
I assumed it'd be 90 known like 10 yes
but there are a lot of serious people
um for you guys listening I just did
this random Twitter poll where I was
like would you take 10 grand if it meant
someone random in the world died and a
lot of the replies on the Tweet were
like hell yeah why not and I was just
not expecting that
um and so I don't really know I mean I
feel like your take would be better than
mine was it disturbing to you surprising
to you a little bit yeah but you know
obviously a lot of people were trolling
but I actually you know you read through
those replies I do think like 10 of them
were like dead serious well I think
sometimes the trolling and the laws
reveal a thing we're too embarrassed to
admit about the darker aspects of our
nature so I don't know if you listen to
Dan Carlin's Hardcore History Podcast he
has a episode on painful infotainment
which he describes throughout history
how humans have been really attracted to
watching The Suffering of others so
public executions all that kind of stuff
and he believes that's in all of us that
for example if something like a YouTube
or a different platform
stream to public execution or streamed
the torture of another human being
a lot of people would uh say that's
deeply unethical but they will still
tune in and watch and that we're we're
attracted to that drama and especially
the most extreme versions of that drama
and so I think part of the laws
reveal something that's actually true in
that poll that like your answer is so
much better than mine do you think about
that maybe even with the squid game like
so I think how many how many views does
this game currently have 300 million
yeah something like this
so
just imagine
a thought experiment how many views that
video would get if it was like real yeah
because I mean YouTube was like We'll
turn a blind out we won't take it down
yeah I mean it I've obviously it
probably have billions of views